qui n'a jamais rêvé de visiter les
coulisses d'une salle de spectacle c'est
choses fait pour une vingtaine de
personnes aguille en cours la ferme de
BBA a dévoilé ses secrets en ouvrant les
portes des coulisses du théâtre
habituellement fermé au
public sommes dans ce que moi j'appelle
la tour de contrôle après un historique
de l'ancienne ferme royale du 17e siècle
les visiteurs voient l'envers du décor
appareil technique métier et
régieendream ludique euh tout ce qui se
passe et que ne voi pas quand ils
viennent voir des spectacles c'est
effectivement notamment extrêmement axé
autour de de la technique du spectacle
donc la lumière le son comment se passe
un montage un démontage la conduite du
spectacle et quels sont les codes à
l'intérieur du théâtre des codes donc
qui permettent aux techniciens de se
comprendre sans prononcer les mots
interdits des mots interdits par
superstition comme corde en référence au
pandaison d'autrefois ça c'est surpris
les visiteurs découvrent un vocabulaire
particulier ce sont les marins qui ont
été les premiers techniciens du
spectable du coup ils ont amené avec eux
euh tout un vocabulaire tout un
glossaire mais aussi tout plein de
superstition la complexité du
vocabulaire euh tout ce qui vient de la
Marine
Le et puis l'histoire aussi de la ferme
de bbaas tout ce qui est au niveau
historique c'était bien sympathique de
savoir d'où ça venait tout ça
voilà les fermes et et puis le côté
marin de de l'origine
de de du vocabulaire surtout et des
superstitions la ferme de BBA propose
chaque année 110 représentations et
reçoit une cinquantaine de compagnies
une équipe de 6 personnes gère le
théâtre qui peut accueillir 354
spectateurs